gayatri asked how do i get 100 uptime  for my serverless system  my answer  you probably shouldn't  most downtime is caused by changes so to  get 100 uptime you should stop deploying  new features and bug fixes  but that would be bad for users we need  a way to balance reliability against  innovation  this is where error budgets come in  let's say we aim for a system to have  99.9 uptime that is a 0.01 downtime  budget  every week we estimate the total  downtime by the end of the quarter  one of two things can happen  if it looks like we will undershoot the  downtime budget we will continue working  on new features  if it looks like we will overshoot we  work on increasing reliability instead  for more on error budgets check out  google's sre book  let me know your questions about google  cloud serverless in the comments